اهلا بكم نبدا من اخر التطورات الميدانيه
لحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث تواصلت
المعارك بين الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني في
مختلف الجبهات الجنوبيه والشرقيه وقالت
سلطات دونيتك المواليه لروسيا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تواصل استهداف المقاطعه وان
سبعه مناطق تعرضت خلال الساعات الماضيه
لاكثر من 150 قذيفه وصاروخا ما اسفر عن
مقتل شخص واحد والحاق اضرار بالمنازل
والبنيه التحتيه
وعلى الخرائط اشتدت حده المواجهات على
الارض بين روسيا واوكرانيا وسط مخاوف
عسكريه من جنود في جبهات القتال في فصل
الشتاء وستحذيرات اوكرانيه من ان اكثر من
170,000 كلم مربع اصبحت اراضي خطره مزروعه
بالالغام عشيده الجبهه الجنوبيه في مناطق
خرسون وميكو لايف وزابولوجيا اصفا متبادلا
بين الجيشين الروسي
اما في الجبهه الشرقيه فوصل الجيش الروسي
وهاجماته على المواقع الاكرانيه في لوغانس
كودونيس
بالمقابل افاد مراسل الجزيره في خرصون
جنوبيه اوكرانيا نقلا عن الجيش الاوكراني
ان القوات الروسيه تشنت خلال الساعات
الماضيه اكثر من 30 هجوما على المدينه
وعلى قرم وبلدات على خط التماسا قال الجيش
ان قوته تبادل القصه المدفعيه مع القوات
الروسيه على طول نهر دنبر في المقاطعه
واضاف ان القصف الروسيه استمر طيله ليله
الماضيه على مقاطع
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها وصلت
تكبير الروس خسائر في مقاطعه
ذكرت وكاله رويترز ان الوالد الولايات
المتحده تستعد لارسال حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
جديده بقيمه 200 و 275 مليون دولار الى
اوكرانيا وفق مصادر الوكاله ووثيقه طلعت
عليها فان حزمه المساعدات ستتيح الاكيد
قدرات جديده للتصدي للطائرات المسيره
وتعزيز دفاعاتها الجويه ومن المتوقعين تضم
الحزمه قذائف لمنظمات الصاروخيه واخيرا من
عيار
2155 ملمترا وعربات عسكريه من طرازها
ومولدات كهربائيه بحسب المصادر والوثيقه
اشترت روترز الى ان وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه قد تعلن عن الحزمه اليوم الجمعه
مقابل التهم الرئيس الروسي ولازمربوتنا
الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها بمحاوله الحفاظ على الهيمنه
العالميه باستخدام القوه قلبوتي في كلمه
المسجله امام المشاركين في اجتماع وزراء
دفاع دولي منظمه تشونغ هاي التعاون ورابطه
الدول المستقله قال ان الغرب يعمل على
مضاعفه مستوى الفوضى عبر زعزعه الاستقرار
في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
سوشا
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها على القوه انهم
في الواقع دمروا اساسا لاستقرار
الاستراتيجي الذي تم انشائه على مدار عقود
ويعملون بقوه على توسيع حلف شمال الاطلسي
ومن اجل احتواء اين نماذج جديده للتنميه
يلجؤون الى العقوبات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
غير القانونيه
ويستخدمون تقنيات الثورات الملونه لازاله
الحكومات المرفوضه من قبلهم واثاره
النزعات العسكريه
الصالحه تزيد من درجه التوتر واحتمالات
المواجهه في مناطق مختلفه من العالم